it is of course undeniable that there
remains the possibility that a bump at
some place or other is connected with a
particular property passion and so forth
one can imagine the murderer with a high
bump here at this place on the skull and
the thief with one there
from this aspect phrenology is capable
of still greater expansion from the
first instance it seems to confine
itself to connecting a bump with a
property in the same individual
that is the individual possesses both
but natural or everyday phrenology for
there must be such a science as well as
a natural physiognomy already goes
beyond this restriction
it not only declares that a cheating
fellow has his bump as big as a fist
behind his ear but also asserts that not
the unfaithful wife herself but the
other conjugal party has a bump on the
forehead
similarly one can imagine the man who is
living under the same roof as the
murderer or even his neighbor or going
further afield imagine his fellow
citizens and so forth with high bumps on
some part or other of the skull just as
well as one can imagine the flying cow
that was first caressed by the crab that
was riding on the donkey etc etc
but if possibility is taken not in the
sense of the possibility of imagining
but in the sense of inner possibility or
the possibility of the notion then the
object is a reality of the kind which is
a pure thing and is and should be
without a significance of this sort and
therefore can therefore have it only in
imagination or picture thinking
in paragraph 336 hegel is going to
contrast two kinds of possibility
one which he is associating with the
imagination and that's got you might say
a wider
range at least
of imaginary possibility
and then there's what he's calling here
inner possibility or the possibility
of the notion
and that seems to be in some respects
more restricted as we're going to see
if we if we reflect on what's going on
here it's not actually more restricted
because the only if we want to play on
words a bit only actual possibility
is that of the inner possibility of the
notion
the
other kind of possibility which seems to
be much wider we might call bear
possibility
or
not really possible possibility again
this will make more sense as we go along
so he begins by saying
it's undeniable that there remains the
possibility
that a bump at some place or another is
connected with a particular property
passion
or so on and this is what phrenology has
been asserting and we've seen that in
order for it to work there's a lot of of
assumptions that would have to be made
about the way in which the skull and the
brain interact and
what spirit is like and all these sorts
of things but hegel is going along with
this now just for a moment and he's
going along with it in a way that really
has something to say to
modern philosophy and to late modern
philosophy as well
so he says look it could really
no not even really it could be imagined
to be the case that some sort of bump
would correspond in some sort of way
unclear at this point to something
having to do with the brain which then
has to do with the person and who they
are as as an individual
we can imagine this
so he says we can imagine the murderer
with a high bump here at this place on
the skull and the thief with one in
another place right and he says from
this aspect phrenology is capable of
still greater expansion
four
it seems to confine itself to connecting
a bump of the property in the same
individual now what is hegel doing here
is he really proposing
that
we should engage in what he's calling
the natural or everyday
phrenology no he thinks that this is
even more off base than the
pseudoscience that pretends to have some
sort of rigor of phrenology that you can
find you know textbooks on from the 19th
century
instead what he's doing is he's doing a
reductio odd absurdum he's going further
and further with the absurdity
of this doctrine in order precisely to
show us that it can't possibly work as
it's purporting to
so he says
natural or everyday phrenology for there
must be such a science as well as a
natural physiognomy goes beyond this
restriction
so what might we imagine it to be saying
it says a cheating fellow not only has a
bump as big as a fist behind
his ear but it also asserts that not the
unfaithful wife herself but the other
conjugal party has a bump on the
forehead you know a batoking luster or
something like that similarly one can
imagine the man who's living under the
same roof as the murderer
or even his neighbor going further
afield his fellow citizens with high
bumps or something like that on one part
of the skull or another so what is he
saying here this you know if we're going
to play around with arbitrary
connections
and we're going to do it out of
imagining things well we can imagine
things going even further why why does
it have to be
the
person himself or herself
who is the thief who has the bump why
couldn't it be their cat
why couldn't it be
the
person down the street why couldn't it
be the person who does their dry
cleaning that has the bump i mean if
we're gonna imagine that bumps somehow
are connected with character traits
the bump doesn't necessarily have to be
on the same person because we can
imagine it right
so what is he doing here he's showing us
the absurdity of relying so much on
imagination
for revealing possibility to us
he says
um
we can just as well
imagine the flying cow that was first
caressed by the crab that was riding on
the donkey and so forth and so forth and
think about these you know songs that we
have about these improbable
circumstances that people sing at summer
camps about bumps on logs and all these
other things that go along there right
uh whether the hole in the bucket you
know dear lines of dear eliza and you
have to go through this whole
progression to get to what what is going
to fix the buckets you know all these
sort of things can in fact be imagined
and it's a lot of fun to do that but if
our goal is to develop something that we
want to
claim as a science
something that we want to call
vissenshaft a way of knowing right this
and shaft
vistan is is knowing knowledge right and
then the shaft a way of a technique of a
a mode of knowing if we're going to do
this then phrenology is is really
falling short unfortunately and the
crazy you know super imaginary
phrenology is just as bad and actually
no worse than the discipline of
phrenology
so what is hegel going to conclude here
he's going to say
you can imagine whatever you like
that's the problem with imagination
so we probably don't want to rely
on imagination and the sort of pseudo
possibility
bear possibility imagined possibility
that it can provide us
with as a guide as an index
instead we need to think in terms of
what we might call real or actual
possibility what really is possible
and that is going to be
something that the notion the concept
thinking through things in a conceptual
begriflica way
is going to reveal to us not this
arbitrary imagining
here i think in in a certain way what he
has in his sights are hume and hume
successors
if you look through hume's works
you will find that he gets a lot of
mileage in a negative way out of saying
that
really you know we can't be
we can't have any assurance in things
like say ah priori proofs about god's
existence or that sort of thing because
you know we work from from analogies
and really when it comes down to it if
we could imagine the possibility of
anything that would confuse these these
proofs
uh or you know make the analogies weaker
anything along those lines
then we should reject it right
that's being it's being used in a
negative sense
phrenology is doing something similar
but it's doing it in a positive way
that's saying oh no we can know
something about the world we can know
something about people's noggins and the
knots in them and then the behavior that
they're going to show
we can do so pre you know precisely
because we can use the imagination and
talk about the possibility of this
phrenology actually doesn't talk about
possibilities so much as claim that it
has laws but hegel's weakening and
saying yeah we can imagine possibilities
that some not actually tells us
something about a person's personality
or individuality
but that's not possibility that leads us
anywhere it reminds me of a great old
expression
from a painted nail only a painted coat
can be hung
you can't actually hang anything on a
nail that's only painted on the wall
except something just as imaginary
and
that's the problem with this you know
phrenology is it it doesn't have a real
basis for the relations that it's
claiming
are uh in fact the case and can be known
from
the bumps on a person's skull
the observer ignoring the mutual
indifference of the two aspects may
nevertheless set to work to determine
their relations partly encouraged by the
general rational principle that the
outer is the expression of the inner
and partly supported by the analogy of
the skulls of animals which indeed may
well have a simpler character than human
beings but of which at the same time it
will be all the harder to say what
character they do have
since it cannot be easy for anyone
really to enter in imagination into the
nature of an animal
should however the observer do so he
will find in assuring us of the
certainty of the laws he claims to have
discovered an excellent aid in a
distinction which must necessarily occur
to us here too
the being of spirit cannot in any case
be taken as something fixed and
immovable
man is free it is admitted that the
original being consists merely of
dispositions about which a man is free
to do much as he wishes or which require
favorable circumstances for their
development
that is that is an original being of
spirit is equally well to be spoken of
as a being that does not exist qua being
were observations therefore to conflict
with what someone happens to maintain is
a law should it happen to be fine
whether at the annual fair or on wash
day
then dealer and housewife might say that
it really ought to rain and that the
tendency to reign is certainly present
so too when observing the skull it might
be said that this individual really
ought to be what according to the law
his skull proclaims him to be and that
he has an original disposition
but one that has not been developed this
quality is not present but it ought to
be present the law and the oauth are
based on observation of actual rainfall
and on the actual significance in the
case of this particular characteristic
feature of the skull
but if the reality is not present the
empty possibility serves equally well
this possibility that is non-actuality
of the stated law and hence the
observations conflicting with the law
inevitably result from the fact that the
freedom of the individual and the
developing circumstances are indifferent
to being as such or to what merely is
indifferent to being both as an original
inner and as an outer osseous form
and this also from the fact that the
individual can be something else than he
is by inner disposition and still more
than what he is as a bone
what hegel is trying to show us and i
think indeed succeeding in showing us in
paragraph 337
is that any discipline like phrenology
that's taking something that's that's an
external
and essentially something that is is
dead or understood as
living but living in the in the mode of
mere being
you know merely organic but not
organic in the sense that we were
looking at before where there's a
spontaneity to it
is going to be inadequate to
making sense out of to providing
intelligibility to let alone predicting
what it is that a human being
will do and and look like and even tend
to do
and we can frame this in terms of the
brain which again is the organ for
spirit right
uh the the organ by which the spirit is
connected with the rest of the body or
we can think of it in terms of spirit or
mind geist can mean either spirit or
mind
and
one of the things that he says about
halfway through that i put at the top of
the board i really want to stress this
because here we're seeing the the hegel
that is going to get picked up on
by
existentialists
who themselves will often be both
turning against hegel for being too
but also using hegel's insights this is
one of those cases of the the power of
the negative he says the original the ur
springlike being sein
of of spirit of geist
is well let me read the actual phrase
because i i've abbreviated a little bit
here the the original being of of spirit
is equally well to be spoken of as a
being
a being that does not exist quoi or as
being
so if we want to talk about
something like a metaphysics of spirit
which is what hegel is indeed trying to
provide us here although it's a
dynamically developing metaphysics
we have to understand that the kind of
being that is actually possessed here is
not the same kind of being as that of
other beings it almost sounds rather
heideggerian or sartrean to say this
sort of stuff
we could say that the the being of a
human being
is not to be what objects are although
it can be reduced to an object as we've
seen for example in the
self-consciousness section
or what's really been going on here in
this entire reason section
as uh observing reason tries to make
sense of
individuality individual reasoning human
beings tries to make sense of them it's
also trying to make sense of itself a
lot
pregnant there in this passage so let's
let's go back to the start he says the
observer ignoring the mutual
indifference of the two aspects the
skull and
on the other side spirit
may nevertheless set to work to
determine their relations
you know it's not just bare possibility
the phrenologist is using these two
things the outer is the expression of
the inner this law which never turns out
to really be a law
that we've been playing around with for
the last you know what
40 50 paragraphs
beginning with the the first section
this first subsection of this section
observing reason
and then he talks about the analogy of
the skulls of animals and this is quite
interesting what he has to say
he says
it may indeed well be the case that
animals have a simpler character than
human beings so maybe it would make
sense to observe the skulls of animals
look at wolves look at bears look at
little bunny rabbits you know we can
compare them against each other what
kind of character do they show the bumps
that they have are those bumps that show
them that to be lecherous animals like
rabbits or to be ravenous animals like
wolves or social animals you know we can
we can only go so far with this right
because we're stuck mostly with birds
and mammals and i suppose some reptiles
maybe fish i suppose you know depending
on how far you want to go with it but
then hagel points out this problem he
says
it's it's harder to say what character
they do have because it's not easy for
anyone really to enter in imagination
into the nature of an animal
it's not enough just to look at it from
the outside the way that natural um
historians would do
back in the the middle ages or in the
ancient period and say you know i think
crocodiles are mean because they they
bite stuff
and you know they they seem very
aggressive
no in order to actually be able to say
what the crocodilian meanness is like
you somehow have to be able to enter
into the skull of the crocodile and
imagine
what it's like to be this creature who's
so alien to our existence
um i i think at this point uh anybody
who's read much uh contemporary 20th
century philosophy would probably bring
up thomas nagle's bat essay
but it's not as if people weren't
speculating about this long before for
example hegel right here saying
it's pretty hard to place ourselves in
the consciousness of an animal even in
imagination
so he says
should the observer do so he will find
in assuring us of the certainty of the
laws he claims to have discovered an
excellent aid in a distinction which
must necessarily occur to us here too
so
he's saying look if you want to draw
this analogy to skulls of animals
here's something you need to take into
account
human beings are animals
human beings are a weird kind of animal
they are almost we might say unique
why
because the human being the mensch as he
says here
is free
dementia's fry
so he goes on and he says
the being of spirit cannot be taken as
something fixed and immovable we can
take the being of other animal
consciousnesses
we understand that they're dynamic they
respond to their their circumstances
their situation they have limited
plasticity
um but for the most part they don't seem
to be all that
flexible all that free compared to human
beings
even pretty
underdeveloped human beings are quite
free
by comparison to other
animals that we could look at other
animals that may in fact be much better
suited to their environment than you
know these bumbling human beings but the
human being is free so he says it's
admitted that the original being
consists merely of dispositions this is
what the phrenologist is actually saying
about which a man is free to do much as
he wishes or which require favorable
circumstances for their development so
there's two conditions there
i might have that bump that you know
it makes me tend to be a murderer right
or maybe it's in my dna we say or you
know
contemporary brain science likes to
locate things and what's going on in the
brain and the chemistry and all that
well
it's not necessitating me
because it is just a disposition an on
log right
so
what's actually going on
well there's not the kind of
determination
that we would like to have and there may
be uh some that require like it says
favorable circumstances so he says an
original being of spirit is equally well
to be spoken of and then we have this
this famous or at least should be famous
sentence here
that you know the original being of
spirit is to be a being that does not
exist quoi
being does not exist as bare being does
not exist in the way of the being of
mere animals
so he goes on and he says
we're observation therefore to conflict
with some what someone maintains to be a
law
this is where it gets very interesting
right
um
when we come up with these things about
say the criminal type or the artistic
type right and we get you know somebody
let's just pretend for a moment that
there's there's an actual correlation
between having a big
you know high brow here and being
artistically creative right now we find
some guy
and he's got that big brow but he hasn't
produced anything and we bring him to
the art museum and we take him to the
gallery and we we dress him in a
painter's outfit and we put him in front
of a canvas we say
express your creativity i know that it's
in you and he just you know kind of
doodles around and you know plays
tic-tac-toe and we're like what's wrong
with this guy
well he clearly is supposed to be is he
just screwing with us
is he abiding his time and we induce him
now imagine in our thought experiment we
you know offer him money and we offer
him prestige and we offer him his his
choice of you know uh available romantic
or sexual partners and we we you know
then we also bring pressure to bear on
them we're going to kill your family if
you don't produce some artistic pieces
they don't have to be masterpieces just
make some art right
and he still doesn't do it
well what's going on there well it's
like what hegel's talking about
it's just like that law about you know
well it always rains when it's at the
fair you know or whenever i take my
washing out and then suddenly it doesn't
rain
what do people do in those circumstances
that's when they say well it should have
rained
it's sort of like there's a disposition
it should have rained but but it didn't
in this one case the next time around it
sure will
you know who's prone to this sort of
sort of belief people who have
stereotypes
gamblers all sorts of you know uh loose
sloppy thinking uh you know it produces
this sort of mindset and hegel's saying
that's what phrenology does
so he talks here about a law
and an ought
and he says the dealer and housewife
would say it really ought to rain and
the tendency to reign is certainly
present so too when observing the skull
it might be said that this individual
really ought to be what according to the
law
his skull proclaims him to be that law
that's being you know produced here
which really isn't a law at all
so he says
the law on the water based on
observation of actual rainfall so they
could be you know statistically
correlated what about the laws that have
to do with people's skulls
are they really
laws in this sense
he says
here we go the actual significance in
the case of this particular
characteristic feature of the skull
would be what we'd look at but if the
reality is not present the empty
possibility serves equally well and here
we go back to what we were talking about
in the last paragraph
phrenology is largely imaginary
and phrenology
or anything else that's like phrenology
that is say looking at the the skull or
you know the physiognomy looking at the
visage the way people walk
we might extend this to you know
thinking about the way people dress or
what skin color they have or the way in
which they use their language all of
these sorts of things
might be very similar to what's going on
here there's these tendencies that's why
i brought up stereotyping right people
stereotype and then when somebody is an
exception that they say oh either that's
one of the good ones or well you know
just give him some time and he'll
conform to the stereotype or you know in
this circumstance this person there's
always some some interesting explanation
but the problem is all these things are
ultimately based on the imagination so
he says
this possibility that is the
non-actuality of the stated law and
hence the observations conflicting with
the law
inevitably result
inevitably result why
from the fact that the freedom of the
individual and the developing
circumstances are indifferent
to being as such
now what does that mean
well
we have a being
that's very clear i i have you know a
certain genetic profile
you can tell i'm of a certain type right
height
i can modify that to a certain degree i
suppose i can stoop down a little bit
but i'm a pretty tall guy
i can get fatter i can get thinner i can
you know work out and have better
musculature but it's never going to get
you know to like weight you know super
weight lifters uh muscles or anything
like that and it's probably not going to
get too bad either even if i just leave
it alone there's certain physical things
within which we we operate right
but though and those are our being those
are those are zion those are
what what we've got right and and we
have certain dispositions right i know
i'm i'm a person who um would be
classified back in the old days probably
as a choleric
disposition right um
means that i tend to be impatient with
with with people and i have to watch it
uh because i i have a tendency to to
take offense too easily or to get upset
about things and it also makes me good
at fighting right
but that's a disposition that doesn't
have to be
exactly what i am being does not
determine
spirit
rather spirit
transcends
mere being
and decides what's going to happen with
it also you know we can talk about these
circumstances too the circumstances
could exist for my talents to be
developed or imagine if i had been born
back in uh you know
some some back water in you know some
rural area in the 1820s
maybe i would uh not have done anything
other than make barrels
might have been happy but you know maybe
some of the talents that i would have
needed in order to get to where i am or
you think about your case as well
would not have been able to be deployed
so hegel goes on and he says
um here we go these are indifferent to
being as such or to what merely is
they're indifferent to being
both as an original inner as an outer
osseous form that's the skull and this
also from the fact that the individual
can be something else than he is by
inner disposition
and still more than what he is as a bone
so this very fact of human beings being
free which doesn't mean that they can do
anything whatsoever right that's that
that's that kind of silly imaginary
possibility but the fact that we do have
some measure of determination of choice
of reflexivity
means that there isn't any law here that
just happens to be
you know
abrogated in our case but the tendency
is there the fact that
that can even happen at all means it's
not a law
and phrenology turns out to be a fraud
we get then the possibility that this
bump or this hollow on the skull may
denote something actual as well as
merely a disposition
one more over that is so ill-defined as
to denote something that is not actual
we see what happens as always to be a
bad subterfuge that is that it is itself
ready to be used against what it is
supposed to support
we see mere subjective imagining brought
by the very nature of the fact to say
but unthinkingly the opposite of what it
affirms to say that by this particular
bone something or other is indicated but
equally to is not indicated
there's not an awful lot to say about
paragraph 338 he's just drawing
a conclusion from the previous
paragraphs but we should follow it
through and you see
where the contradiction
is arising and this is a contradiction
that hegel takes as sort of a a stopping
point you know you know that
contradiction can sometimes work in a
very productive way in the hegelian
system but this is one way saying look
you know there isn't supposed to be this
kind of contradiction there and you're
not really doing anything productive
with it so clearly there's a problem
with phrenology says
we get then the possibility this bumper
hollow may denote something actual is
where as well as merely a disposition
but the the disposition stuff doesn't
really work because as we've seen just
in the previous paragraph
these dispositions don't determine us
the way that they would say other
animals
and so
because we are free
not necessarily even radically free but
free vis-a-vis the disposition
um
the disposition can't be seen as
something
determinative and so if we're going to
connect the skull up with it and say
that's this disposition is signified by
this bump
not not very helpful so he goes on and
he says we see what happens to bad
subterfuge there's there's a sleight of
hand going on here
that it is itself ready to be used
against what it is supposed to support
so what we see here
is a kind of contradiction occurring
right
and the contradiction reveals to us the
weakness of the position
so he says we see mere subjective
imagining that's what's been relied upon
here
brought to the very brought by the very
nature of the fact
the conditions under which we've been
looking at to say
but unthinkingly the opposite of what it
affirms so it says two things
at the same time that can't both be the
case he says something is indicated by
this bone and that something that we're
talking about here could be something
actual something that the person does
murders right or the disposition to
murder or the write poetry those are his
his
preferred examples
but it also says that something is not
indicated
it's not
being
expressed
as necessary to that that person is not
necessarily going to happen just like
the rain that should come at wash time
but
doesn't show up this time well he didn't
murder today let's watch him a bit
longer maybe he never murders his entire
life doesn't that bump really mean that
he was a murderer the whole time but
just didn't have his opportunity no you
would you would presume that it should
show up so
you know that that's the problem with
relying upon subjective imagining and
this is something to bring this back to
hume again that um you know we saw as a
problem coming up in hume and also we
might add in blaze pascal you can
imagine anything you like
imagining
can't be taken
as an index
by itself
for what really is the case
it can't even be taken adequately
to rule out what can't be the case
so this is a big problem because
phrenology
as it turns out doesn't have the the
intellectual
weight that it needs in order to get
past the fact that its basis is
subjective imagining